فيديو جديد متداول يجدد الرعب من مخدر
الزومبي وفي تفاعلكم نحاول الوصول لكل ما
يمكن عن المخدر الغامض واخر صيحات رب ضد
منافسه تحتاج زراعه شخصيه
والديمقراطيه اخر المهددين بسبب الذكاء
الاصطناعي حسب تقرير على الاقل اهلا بكم
[موسيقى]
متداول جديد اليوم لكن في مثل كثير ومن كل
دول العالم
[موسيقى]
مؤخرا شايفين تحركات عربيه لمكافحه هذه
الانواع من المخدرات الاردن عملات حمله
عليهم مصر كل شويه بتعلم ضبط عصابات مختصه
بالترويج والبيع السعوديه طبعا لسه من كم
يوم اعلنت احباط تهريب اكثر من 106 كيلو
من هذه الماده من منافذ حدوديه تحركات
يعني في كل مكان والاسئله صراحه كثيره
فمثلا ايش تفرق هذه المخدرات عن الانواع
الثانيه اللي معروفه من زمن وليه بيسموها
الزومبي خلونا نستفسر من ضيفتنا المختصه
اللي بتنضم الينا من جده دكتوره فاطمه
محمد كاكي استشاريه اولى طب نفسي وعلاج
الادمان اهلا فيك معنا دكتوره فاطمه اول
شيء خلينا نحاول نفهم منك ايش الفرق بينها
وبين المخدرات اللي اعتدنا السماع عنها
الكوكايين والهيروين وما الى ذلك
اشكرك واشكر القناه العربيه على الاستضافه
وعلى الموضوع الجميل وخاصه حمله السعوديه
وحمله العالم العربي ضد المخدرات او حرب
على المخدرات اولا خليني اتكلم عن الشبو
او الزومبي او الفلاكه هذا من المنشطات
بدا فيها عالم ياباني اسمه ناغه يوشي في
1893 اضاف على الانفيتامين عده مواد وطلع
ماده الكريستال او الشبوك جوفي الحرب
العالميه الثانيه
استخدمت المانيا النازيه على الجنود على
اساس تحسن جوده الجنود وكده كده هم
هيموتوا انهزموا ويموتوا يا انه ينتصروا
ويموتوا طب ايش هو الشبو يعني كثير ناس
يقول لك لا يا دكتور الشبو زي الهيروين لا
الهيروين غير والشبو غير هو ماده منشطه
منبهه للجهاز العصبي المركزي يشتغل على
النواقل العصبيه وخاصه ماده الدوبامين
اللي هي بتشتغل على الحركه ولذه بالحياه
امازون فهد ماده الشبو بتشتغل على عالميا
حسب منظمه الصحه العالميه ل 2023 35 مليون
متعاطي الشبو في العالم
عكس زمان كان يعني لسه بالعشرينات 22 وشوي
شوي شوي صار 25 دحين صار 35 مليون عالميا
يتعاطى الشبو وفئه عمريه صغيره الشباب
اللي هم من 18 الى 25 اللي هم ثروه البلد
يعني اغلب
فيعني فهذا هو السبب كيف طب يفرقوا عن
المواد الثانيه انه عالي يشتغل على على
المراكز الوظيفيه المعرفيه على اساس كده
بيؤدي الى انه هو بيحفز الانسان ويؤدي الى
سلوك عدواني فممكن يقتل الوقت ايوه هذا هو
يمكن هذه واحده من الجزئيات اللي عليها
كثير جدل انه
بيربطوها دائما على طول بالعنف
ومو اي عنف يعني نحن بنت كلم على انه شخص
يقتل
ايوه نعم صحيح لان هو يشتغل على الدوبامين
واشتغل على الفصه الجبهه اللي هو فيه
الوظائف المعرفيه طيب تساليني ايش هي
الوظائف المعرفيه الوظائف المعرفيه اللي
هي تميز الانسان عن اي كائن ثاني يعني حي
فالانسان ربي اكرمه بوظائف معرفيه التفكير
الانتباهي بالتاكيد
فاطمه جالسه عشان انا اسمعكم وانتم
تسمعوني واكون واعي عن سلوكي تصرفاتي
وكلامي لكن اللي يتعاطى الشبو يفقد هذه
الميزه فيفقد فيصير عدائي فهو اكثر عداوته
على اهله فدحين القصص انه واحد قتل ابوه
المقعد قتل امه
فهذه الحوادث يعني كلها يقول لك طب ليش هل
ممكن احنا نعالجه في البيت انا امس بتحكي
لي وحده دكتوره انا قولي لي ايش الطريقه
وانا احبس واعاجي قلت لها لا يعني ممكن
الاضطرابات الزهانيه بالاضافه او الوظائف
المعرفيه مضروبه عنده
الهلاوس بتجي له اصوات امك تؤذيك ابوك
تاذيك اخوك
القصه انه كان عندنا مريض خرج من الطائف
ورجع البيت وهو انتكس بسرعه
فاعطوا له شابوا فريح على اخوه لانه اصوات
بتقول له اخوك يحبه ابوك اكثر منك وراح
سلخ راسه من من جسده ورماه على وجه ابوه
وهذه قصه حقيقيه سجلت قبل اربع سنين يعني
بسبب انه الاصوات والارضات الجزئيه اللي
بتجيله شغاله فيه فهذا يعني صراحه للامانه
يعني هو ده سبب العنف والعدائيه حقت الامن
وبيقولوا كمان انه اسرع الادمان عليه اسرع
الوقوع فيه انه الواحد ممكن من اول مره
يدمن نعم ممكن وبالذات يعني اغلب الشباب
والشابات بيستخدموه وبيتستلزه لان هو يحفز
يعطيه طاقه يعطي نشاط يعطيه تركيز فكل
شويه بيزودوا الجرعه عشان يكونوا اكثر
نشاط ويسوي يعني بهجه
وفرك مود نفس اللي هي البهجه اللي في
الهيروين عشان كذا في ناس بيقول لك طب هو
زي الهي
منشط لكن مع الاسف التجار اللي اشتغلوا
على الشبو لقوه رخيص وبتصنع من ماده
الكبتاجون او الانفيتامين عشان كذا الدوله
حفظها الله انه ضبطت كميات كبيره بحيث
انها تمنعها لانهم بدهم يجيبوا الان
فيتامين ويصنعوا منه الشبو لانه الشبو
لوحده لازم الماده الرئيسيه كثير ناس هو
الماده الاساسيه لتصنيع الشبو الانفتامين
او الكبتاجون بالمفهوم العام يضيفوا عليه
مواد حنذكرها يعني طيب وتحت الفكره ان
احنا بنشكرك على هذه المداخله كانت معنا
من جده دكتوره فاطمه محمد كاكي استشاريه
اولى طب النفسي وعلاج الادمان شكرا لك
بعد القصه اللي راح اشاركها معكم الان
حتتاكدوا ان العمر مجرد رقم وانه ما في
شيء يمنع الانسان من تحقيق اهدافه الدكتور
عبد الله القويس دبلوماسي ومصرفي سعودي
متقاعد في الثمانيه من عمره قرر يبدا رحله
اقل ما يقال عنها ان مغامره بكل مال
الكلمه من معنى مغامره الدكتور عبد الله
هي تسلق جبال الهملايا بهدف الوصول الى
قمه افرست اللي ببلغ ارتفاعها اكثر من
8000 و800 متر ودكتور عبد الله بيوثق
رحلته بشكل لطيف على تويتر فبيكتب تغريدات
وبيحط صور وفيديوهات وفي وحده من
التغريدات حتى كمان عن قيامه بهذه الرحله
ردا على سؤال بولنديه حسناء حسب ما وصفها
مدير التمويل مشاريع احد بنوكهم سالته ما
دفعك لذلك في هذا العمر فانه هو تحديدا
عمره 84 فقال انه تحدي النفس ديننا يحث
على محاربه النفس التي تدفع
للاستكانه وللعيش الرقيق مقاطع فيديو
كثيره وثقت رحلات او لحظات من رحله دكتور
عبد الله وهو بيحاول تسلق جبل الهملايا
بهمه وعزم للوصول للقمه خلينا نشوف بعضها
سوا
استمتع
[موسيقى]
يا سكوتر خليك هناك عشان لولا سمح الله
من قوتك
للسير
لازم تصير شديد
حتى تصل الى الهدف
ان شاء الله
واحنا في المخيم الاساسي
[موسيقى]
على الانتخابات الرئاسيه الامريكيه
والرئيس السابق والمرشح الحالي دونالد
ترامب شغاله حملته واعلاناته على كل
الاصعده وطبعا اسلوبه في الهجوم على خصومه
معروف واجدد الخصوم منافسه في قلب حزبه
حاكم فلوريدا
من الاول نازل في هجومه واهانات يمين
ويسار
يعني
اللي هو اسمه كده انه بيجمع فيه بين اسم
ران وبين كلمه منافق بالانجليزيه طيب
عموما مثل ما سمعته ترامب بيقول انه لدى
ديسانتس او انه
انت بحاجه لعمليه او لعمليه زراعه شخصيه
تحديدا الهجوم ما وقف هنا فتره مو شايف
انه حاجه ديسونطي لزرع الشخصيه هي المشكله
طلعت هذه اخاف مشاكله عند تربي يعني لا
شايف المشكله انه في شيء مختلف اكبر
يعني مو المشكله ان الرجال محتاج زرع
شخصيه لا المشكله انه العلم لسه ما توصل
لهذا النوع من العمليات يعني مالك امل
يعني فيعني فوق الاهانه جرح اضافي عموما
تفضلوا اسمعوا التصريح كامل وشوفوا الصفعه
الافتراضيه اللي وجهها ترب المنافس
وبمناسبه الحديث على الانتخابات في موضوع
ثاني مهم عن الانتخابات ممكن نتكلم فيفا
حاليا مثل ما نكون شايف يعني طبعا
الانتخابات الرئاسيه والتشريعيه التركيه
شغاله الحملات الانتخابيه للرئاسه
الامريكيه شغاله كمان والانتخابات منتظره
السنه الجايه هذه السنه في كمان
الانتخابات الروسيه الرئاسيه وغيرها يعني
الانتخابات عموما حول العالم ما توقف وفي
نفس الوقت مؤخرا الذكاء الاصطناعي ساير
موضوع رئيسي في كل المجالاته بس للمختصين
بس كمان لعموم الناس اللي بدات تاخذ او
تنتبه لهذا الموضوع وتركز فيه وكاله اي بي
نزلت تقرير امس بيدق ناقوس الخطر وفي
بتتكلم عن خطوره او خطوره ممكن يشكلها
الذكاء الاصطناعي على الانتخابات تقرير اي
بي بيقول انه الذكاء الاصطناعي الان
والديب فيك بتسهل فبركه الصور والصوت
والفيديوهات وممكن كذا توصل للناس معلومات
غلط يبنوا عليها اصواتهم زي مثلا فيديو
مفبرك لي ايلون ماسك
او فيديو مفبرك لمرشح بيعمل شيء سيء وهو
ما عمله هذه امثله لكن غير تقرير فيه هذا
كمان في كلام صاير عن خطوره مستقبليه او
خطوره مستقبليه للذكاء الاصطناعي على
الانتخابات في تزوير وفبركه الاصوات وانها
ممكن بطريقه ما تظهر اصوات لجهه او شخص او
حزب ماء وهذه الاصوات ما لها وجود في
الحقيقه فمن الاخر كده يعني نقدر نسال انه
هل فعليا الذكاء الاصطناعي خطر على
الانتخابات
والديمقراطيه خلونا نحاول نجاوب على هذه
الاسئله مع ضيفنا المختص في التكنولوجيا
كريم فريد وللو تجربه شخصيه مع مختصه في
الذكاء الاصطناعي اهلا فيك معانا
طيب خليني يعني ابتدي التقرير مقلق يعني
اصلا احنا كل الفتره الاخيره هذه كل شوي
بنسمع عن اشياء الذكاء الاصطناعي كانه
خلاص يعني حيجي ياكلنا يعني خلاص انتهينا
بسببه طيب هل ممكن نحن فعلا انه نلاقي انه
الناس مثلا
يعني خلاص تصويتات وهميه بسبب الذكاء
الاصطناعي الشخصيات امتحان شخصيات
بالتاكيد لان الذكاء الصناعي غير قادر حتى
اللحظه ان هو بينتحل شخصيه حد فيزيكال
يكون موجود بنفسه في اللجنه عشان يقدر فهو
ما فيش مستحيل يكون في تلاعب في
الانتخابات بشكل مباشر ان يحصل تزويق طبعا
انت الان بتعتمد على انه التصويت حاليا
لازم يكون انه شخصي يعني طيب اذا انتقلنا
لمرحله تانيه زي ما كل شيء في الدنيا جالس
بينتقل لمرحله انه لا نحن حنقدر نصوت مثلا
الكترونيا يعني في تقنيات كتير تقدر ان هي
تحمي عمليه التصويت من اي عمليه تزوير
ممكنه عن طريق توثيق هو الشخص بشكل
ديجيتال واذا كانت
التوثيق هيكون
التصويت هيكون ديجيتال ففي اليات كتير
تقدر من خلالها
الحكومات ان هي تحمي عمليه التصويت وعمليه
الانتخابات بالكامل ولكن الخوف اعتقد اكتر
هنا ان هو خوف من
التلاعب او التاثير على الناخبين ما قبل
عمليه الاقتراع وهنا ده الفيديوهات دي فيك
الاشياء دي كلها ولكن الذكاء الاصطناعي
بقى له سنين بيتطور
كل العالم فادلوقتي ولقى ايه ده احنا
عندنا زكاه اصطناعي اعتقد اللحظه الفارقه
عند الناس كانت الشات جي بي تي
بس اعتقد قبلها يعني ما الناس حست انه
داخل في كل شيء في حياتنا اوردي الذكاء
الاصطناعي بالضبط موجود في كل حاجه موجود
في التليفونات تقدر على تليفون التليفون
كل شخص فينا في عدد لا نهائي من تطبيقات
الذكاء الاصطناعي من اول الصور اللي
بنشوفها وازاي بندور عليها لغايه الصوت
لغايه السماعه لما بنحطها في ودننا بيتم
تعديل الصوت بالذكاء الاصطناعي الذكاء
الاصطناعي مفيد جدا في كل حاجه احنا
بنعملها في حياتنا ومفيد لكل نقدر نقول
البيزنس مفيد لكل وسائل الاعلام مفيد لكل
الناس في مخاوف اه في مخاوف السوشيال
ميديا لما ابتدت كان محدش كان متخيل ان هي
هتغير شكل الاعلام هتخلي شركات هتخلي
مؤسسات اعلاميه عملاقه تفلس ومؤسسات ثانيه
قدرت ان هي تتطور بسرعه وتواكب التغيير
اللي بيحصل هنا اللي بيحصل مع الذكاء
الاصطناعي الحكومات والافراد والمؤسسات
قدامهم فرصه يتطوروا بسرعه ويواجهوا
التغيير ويستغلوه ويعتبروه فرصه او انهم
هيحصل لهم زي ما حصل مع وسائل الاعلام بس
لا لحظه هو يعني نحن موضوع مثلا يعني غيرت
اكتر من بس وسائل الاعلام غيرت اشياء جدا
كثيره في حياتنا والكلام ده كله وفي لا
زالت الى الان حتى مخاوف اخلاقيه وما قدرت
ايش من هذه الوسائل بس لما بنتكلم عن
الذكاء الصناعي نحن في كلام انه هو
حيستبدلنا كافراد كاشخاص الطالب ما حيدرس
حيروح يودي البيبر او البحث هو هيعمل له
اياه كل هذه الامور بالتاكيد لا لان هنا
هو اعتني احنا بنتكلم فيه اداه جديده دخلت
حياتنا احنا محتاجين نطور الادوات
والاليات اللي احنا بنستخدم بها كل حاجه
على سبيل المثال بما ان احنا يعني الاعلام
تحديدا في الاعلام حتى الان اذا كان
الصناعي غير قادر ان هو يكون مبدع هو اداه
لزياده الانتاجيه
ولكن و توفير وقت
لكنه غير مبدع ومش هيقدر يكون مبدع في اي
وقت قريب اوكي فبالتالي هو بيتبع اوامر
يساعدك
بشكل عام الابداع بشكل كبير جدا لان هو
عنده ذاكره اقوى كتير مننا ولكن احنا
مبدعين هو مش مبدع احنا قادرين ان احنا
نفكر في زاويه مختلفه
الدافع للابداع ايه التجارب اللي مر بها
لا ما عادي يا غزوه بتجارب الناس اي غزوه
بتجارب الناس ولكن حتى اللحظه هو غير مبدع
غير قادر على حل مشكله ايجاد حل جديد لان
هو اسمه جنريتيف اي اي جينيريتيف ايه اي
اي ببساطه هو ايه هو بيدرس الاحتمالات
وبيحط كلمات جنب بعض بدون تفكير فيها فهو
حتى اللحظه الذكاء الصناعي اللي كل الناس
خايفه منه هو ما بيفكرش هو مجرد بيبص
كلمات جنب بعض بناء على احتمالات
استخدامها من
افهم من كلامك انه حتى الان لازال البشر
هم اللي متحكمين في الذكاء الصناعي هم
اللي بيدخلوا البيانات بداخل هذا الزكاء
الاصطناعي فنحن زي اللي بنعطيه له هذه
الامور بالضبط وهو ثاني غير قادر على
التفكير ما بيفكرش مجرد بنقص الموضوع
علينا لان هو اسرع ولانه هو عنده ذاكره
اقوى مننا لكنه مش
بيفكرنا السويتش خلاص هينطفل سويتش بصفر
في كل حاجه الخوف منه هنا مثلا مثلا في
مساله الانتخابات باننا بنتكلم عنها لو ان
في
الاليات الالات المستخدمه في عمليه
الانتخابيه متوصله بالانترنت هنا تقدري
تخافي منها لكن هي ما ينفعش تكون متوصله
بالانترنت فبالتالي مفيش تاثير للذكاء
الاصطناعي عليه طيب نحنا بنشكرك على هذه
المداخله كان معنى كريم فريد المختص في
التكنولوجيا شكرا لك مشاهدينا
احنا وصلنا لختام حلقه اليوم انا اعود
والقاكم غدا ان شاء الله في حلقه جديده من
تفاعلكم في امان الله
[موسيقى]